[Music]
hey have you been on twitter during the
last weeks
or were you on holidays like me
because if you wear on twitter there is
zero chance that you weren't hit by
somebody posting about stable diffusion
just look at all of this
what is stable diffusion you ask from
your hammock
well a stable diffusion is an open
source alternative to dali 2.
so unlike dali 2 which is hidden behind
an api and a paywall stable diffusion is
a text to image generator like dali but
has open sourced its code then the
weights for academic purposes and so
very recently it has even released the
model weights for everyone
today we explain latent diffusion models
which is the algorithm that stands
behind stable diffusion
and latent diffusion models or short
ldms are a special kind of the more
general class of diffusion models
about which you may or may not have
heard already so if you're interested in
how stable diffusion works this might be
just the right video for you
but before we dive into today's
explanations let's thank assembly ai for
sponsoring today's video
do you know that feeling when you have
hours and hours of audio data lying
around and you want to transcribe it
automatically yes i do know that feeling
especially because i do not want to
enter the captions manually for every
video i do but luckily assembly ai can
help me transcribe my audio with state
state-of-the-art apis for automatic
speech recognition
and you can use their apis too to
automatically convert recorded audio but
wait there is more you can even
transcribe in real time live audio
streams into text which can come in
handy for conferences or other live
streams and believe me that assembly
ai's models do not stop there it can
even help you understand your audio data
for example it can summarize the content
and detect the topic of what is being
said
or it can automatically tag bad words if
one happens to slip out
so what are you waiting for check out
assembly ai with the link in the
description below i for example used
assembly ai to transcribe my speech for
this spot and you can see in the
subtitle how well it works
and think about it i am quite a hard
example for speech transcription with my
eastern european accent
now back to the video first let's recap
what diffusion models are for more
details about this for example on
classifier free guidance do check out
our previous videos on this but as far
as our explanations of diffusion models
in general go
this video has the technically most
correct version because we cleared up a
confusion that miss coffee bean had this
whole time
but let's not get ahead of ourselves and
talk about diffusion models first the
diffusion process is where you diffuse
more and more noise into your image
so you take an image and in t steps you
gradually add more noise to it until
it's the last time step t the image is
approximately just noise
diffusion models go in the opposite
direction of diffusion so in other words
they learn to reverse the diffusion
process
when we are trying to generate an image
with a diffusion model we follow each of
these t steps and reduce the noise
gradually step by step for this we use
the same neural network so it's just one
neural network usually a unit to go from
step t to step t minus one and here for
visualization purposes we have chosen a
step t to be a noisy dog and step t
minus 1 to be a less noisy version of
the dog short side note on units a unit
is a convolution based neural network
that is down sampling an image into a
lower dimensional representation
and reconstructs it during upsampling
the downsampling and upsampling stacks
of layers communicate through skip
connections
and now what is exactly the input to the
neural network
it's an image at step t
and the neural network's output is the
total noise that should be subtracted
from the noisy version of the image at
step t to reconstruct the original image
so the clear picture of the dog wait
let's untangle this a bit and
recapitulate the whole diffusion thing
from the beginning because it is an
important detail that miss coffee bean
got wrong so far
of course i knew the correct version all
the time
unfortunately the papers are not so
clear about this point and how it's done
becomes clear from the code the
diffusion process is all about going
from little noise to more noise
the backward diffusion process is the
reverse and this is what we do with the
help of diffusion models
in the diffusion model itself so this
one unit that we apply at each step gets
a noisy image at step t and predicts the
whole noise that the image contains and
not just the noise we need to subtract
to get from t to t minus one
it's just that we do not trust the model
enough to just subtract this whole noise
in one go so at each step we extract
just a fraction of the total noise from
the image at time step t
reasons for going step by step is that
we break down a hard problem of
generating an image from just noise into
t steps where each step can correct and
improve upon the previous one especially
when the whole time we are trying to
inject textual information when doing
text to image generation it's easier to
inject textual information gradually
than all at once
okay so this was basically an erratum to
our previous videos where we thought
that at each step the model predicts
only a fraction of the noise
but actually the diffusion model
predicts the total amount of noise from
which we then subtract only a fraction
of it to give it afterwards yet another
go at denoising
but now how does the text come into play
it is injected into the whole process in
two ways first as input to the diffusion
model by concatenating the text
representation coming from a language
transformer to the image input
and second through cross attention
letting the unit attention layers attend
to the text tokens
now what about stable diffusion and how
does this work
the idea behind stable diffusion was
introduced in this cvpr paper called
high resolution image synthesis with
latent diffusion models from heidelberg
folk who now moved to munich
the authors proposed latent diffusion
models or short ldms to address a
shortcoming of diffusion models
when trying to generate a large image
such as a 1024 by 1024 image then the
unit in here would have to take in 1024
by thousand twenty four dimensional
noise grid and produce an image out of
it as you can imagine this can become
really expensive for one step and one
has to do it t times where t can be
something like hundred fifty what people
did to circumvent this high
dimensionality problem as we have seen
in the glide paper for example is that
they actually train their diffusion
models on much smaller images like 256
times 256 and then have an extra neural
network that learned to up sample and
sharpen 256 times 256 to higher
resolution for example and this is one
way to do it
but ldm's take another approach
the core concept of ldms is to surrender
the idea of working in the image space
and work on the latent space instead
you may think of it as of an autoencoder
encompassing the diffusion model as
follows for diffusion models we had the
original image to which we then added
more noise but now we do not work with
the image itself but with a lower
dimensional representation of it because
we take the image and run it through an
encoder which is basically a gang
this encoder also has a decoder to
reconstruct the image this encoder and
decoder are trained together first to
encode the image into a lower
dimensional space and then reconstruct
the image from it
now instead of applying noise onto the
image for the diffusion step we apply
noise onto the lower dimensional
representation of the data and for the
backward diffusion the unit works with
this representation instead of the whole
image since the image representation is
lower dimensional the unit does not have
a lot of heavy lifting to do even more
by compressing the image first through
the encoder the encoder decoder can take
care of image details and let the
diffusion model focus on the important
things like image semantics
this makes ldms much faster than usual
diffusion models so this enables us to
run stable diffusion on laptop hardware
instead of clusters or you know
open ai servers
we hope you see how clever but similar
ldms are to what previous work like
glide did
glide took an image down sampled it from
let's say 1024 squared pixels to 256
resolution with a usual image
downsampling algorithm so it was staying
in image space then glide ran diffusion
and upsampled the result to get a higher
resolution image
now with ldms instead of a standard down
sampling algorithm that produces low
resolution images the ldm encoder takes
a high resolution image and embeds it
into a compressed code of its own that
captures the semantics of the image but
in a space that does not look to us like
the original image anymore and the
diffusion model can take it from there
as you can see from the paper the
author's initial work on ldm's was
producing images of human faces and
objects this is because the model whose
output we see in figure 1 was trained on
human faces and objects and you know
what kind of data comes into the
diffusion model this is what they also
produce what makes stable diffusion so
special and fit for art generation
is that it was actually an ldm trained
on a core data set consisting of we cite
leon aesthetics a soon to be released
subset of leian 5b
leon aesthetics was created with a new
clip-based model that filtered leon 5b
based on how beautiful an image was
building on ratings from the alpha
testers of stable diffusion
and this different training data makes
it have its own style that is different
from other text to image generators like
dali 2 mid journey or imagine so to sum
up what is now stable diffusion it is
basically the work that follows the
latent diffusion model's paper where
authors of the paper teamed up with
stability ai and community such as in
luther ai and leon now with stable
diffusion we have an image generator
tuned to produce art as it was trained
on beautiful images which were often
produced by human artists
it will be interesting to see what kind
of new copyright law these ai
generations will spawn
some artists feel bad to see that an ai
can now do something in seconds that
took them hours to make but other
artists consider the ai to be a sort of
a tool which still needs human input
in the human hours that go into the
diffusion based image generation is not
a neglectable amount
just think about the hours one can spend
in tuning the text prompt and waiting
for the right result to come out
only to notice that the astronaut is
riding the horse again when i actually
wanted the horse riding the astronaut on
the moon
if you are interested in using stable
diffusion yourself then check out the
diffusers library or any other helpful
tutorials out there because it's really
amazing what the community has put out
in such a short amount of time in terms
of documentation and in terms of
generations just look at this twitter
user bringing their four year olds
sketches to life well do you think this
is creativity
we are so curious to know what you think
about this so we'll be watching the
comment section closely
miss coffee bean now it's time to say
goodbye see you in the next video
okay bye